I will be giving an overview of really
the why of why we built wasm starting
from the very beginning from the
evolution from the past to the present
and a little bit on the future
and that started for me back in 2012
this is the year that I graduated from
college
and it started with a technology called
azim.js I had this problem where I had
just given a demo and it was terrible I
rendered an application with basically
15 frames per second and that was
because I was trying to come up with a
portable way to run code in the web but
what I had created was a heavy server
connected over a websocket and then like
a light client that was that was
rendering but then I discovered this
blog post by alun zakai and he talked
about asm.js as this super efficient
subset of JavaScript that when targeted
from C plus plus and and compiled to it
you would be able to run basically C
plus plus code in the browser and hype
okay well that's crazy
um I gotta try it out so I read a bunch
about it but really what convinced me is
this demo here and I have to switch to
Firefox just because that's the true
experience audience let me see here we
go
hit high resolution and so this demo
here is called banana bread
it's it's a marina shooter and what will
happen in a second is basically what
happened to me the first time that I
played this which is a bot spawns and it
takes me out but I pulled out this this
game and basically blew my mind I jumped
up from my desk and I immediately walked
uh down to okay we'll stop
I immediately walked down to the corner
office and in that corner office was my
director who I just given this terrible
demo to you but also in there was the VP
my VP the head of engineering
um this is a kind of a mid to large size
company I was working at SAS and these
were suit people this is my first year
out of school I just gave these guys a
really terrible demo so normally what I
would do in that situation is
immediately turn on my heel and run away
but I was so excited that I just kind of
went right on in I showed them that
exact same demo that I just showed you
and I logged on their desktop and we
started playing it and uh it really just
caught fire because if I can do that in
a browser I can render some graphs which
is really what I was trying to do so we
had about a million lines of C plus plus
code and really similar to what Kelsey
was talking about before this code
actually was ported from C to Java later
to flash and now we're trying to come up
with an answer for flash now that it's
basically deprecated in browsers and
what we also were doing around this time
in 2012 was trying to support mobile app
development and so what you ended up
having is the software stack that looks
a little bit like this where you've got
a C plus plus so you can pile it to a
bunch of different targets you had a ton
of different hose glue but also part of
that host glue is necessary for
rendering The View
so naturally I added M scripting which
is the tool chain created by alone to
let me basically build C plus plus code
and Target as in JS and so this was just
really incredible I wrote a lot of
JavaScript code glue to actually make
this work well as an application but it
really did just work so that kind of
blew my mind because I was basically
taking
what I would consider the greatest hack
of all time taking a high level language
and finding ways to make it optimized so
that it can be a low-level compilation
Target something else I want to call out
around this time is in 2014 I went to a
talk at cppcon and the Dropbox team was
talking about a language IDL because
they were doing exactly the same thing
we were doing which is taking portable C
plus code and finding a way to share
that code and run it across a lot of
different platforms and so they had an
IDL that I'm showing here mainly because
I am embarrassed to show you the XML
that I wrote for doing basically the
same thing but also it's going to be
very familiar once I talk about it later
now there was another amazing demo that
happened in 2013 that really helped
osm.js Catch Fire the Mozilla team
partnered with the epic games team and
they ported the unreal game engine in
five days so this type of technical demo
really caught a lot of people's
attention and it brought people to the
table like me a conventional bi
analytics application building with that
Tech meant that they were really real
use cases and crazy enough people to go
and try this and ship applications and
so what that also meant is that now all
the browser vendors got together and
said okay you know we could push forward
a specification for the greatest hack of
all time and that would benefit a lot of
people but what if we started new what
if we started from scratch from
principles for Designing something that
is web native what would we build if we
did that now essentially what we landed
with we're all here today so we already
know it's pretty awesome but it's web
native in that it is it needs to be fast
to download fast to start it needs to
have a really small memory footprint it
needs to be portable because it's code
that I'm going to be running on a lot of
different machines running in different
browsers it also needs to be
just as safe and say unboxable as
JavaScript
now what really made it real for me is
this demo which is yes I know yet
another game demo but this is uh the
unity game engine this was in 2016 this
was like one of the first like really
cool like wow they built this
webassembly Tech it actually works and
I've got this really complex rendering
that's happening in the browser
um now the reason why I keep showing you
game demos is for a few different
reasons uh games are really one of the
most complicated software engineering
projects that we can work on it pulls
across many different disciplines
also the developers are uh the kind of
people that want to use Cutting Edge
technology to get the most out of
hardware and software so as far as Tech
demos go they're they're one of the the
most fun and they're the ones that you
can put in the hands of other people and
say check this out this is real
so by uh 2017 we basically hit
webassembly MVP ship first and Firefox
but then you know immediately after in
Chrome around 2017 was when I also
shipped my app to production with
webassembly and I remember in 2018 how
the performance just got faster and
faster and improved now the biggest deal
here is in 2019 that's when webassembly
officially became the fourth language of
the web up to this point we only had
HTML JavaScript and CSS
to make a an official language of the
web it means that we got a lot of things
out of it but we also had to come up
with a lot of ways to reach MVP and
issued a lot of different features uh
including things like garbage collection
and tail calls but those are later added
and so what we got was something that
was sandboxable and is really in a lot
of ways pretty simple it's just a
compilation Target that many different
languages can support
and I usually call it a bunch of numbers
in a trench coat because at the end of
the day it the web assembly module
itself can't do anything unless it's
handed a function call from the host and
so a lot of times you'll hear people say
deny by default but can you really deny
something when it's not even able to
make that call to break out of the
sandbox at all so with something that is
as simple as this type of thing we were
able to get a lot of adoption really
fast I wasn't the only person building
applications in 2019 I started seeing
implementations really across the web a
lot of cool Tech demos that happened
around that time include stuff from
Adobe and
well just it seemed like everybody was
at the table I believe Shopify showed up
around then so 2019 was a huge year for
webassembly including the introduction
of the webassembly systems interface
now over time over the past several
years it's really evolved from just
being a systems interface when it was
first introduced in 2019 we were really
thinking of it as some approximation to
running on posits to make it really easy
for you to take a waza module and embed
it in a non-web use case
I do want to call out from the very
beginning even in 2015 the original use
case and goals documents in the
webassembly design repo was included
both web and non-web embedding so from
the very beginning we knew this was one
of those cases that we wanted to solve
now quasi itself is is really that arrow
that I have here it's that function call
that I was talking about that gives the
webassembly module the ability to do a
lot of different things like file i o
and networking that it itself isn't
capable of doing but even more
importantly it allows for granular
Imports of those functions and so I can
specify just for one was a module
because it needs it it says it needs
access to you the system clock well now
my webassembly host is in charge of
sandboxing that capability and how that
implementation works so I can add
something like fuzzing of the time so
that you can't get an exact system time
for security reasons
another amazing thing that happened in
2019 is the bytecode alliance was found
formed so uh we knew and and I really
wasn't part of this I was more like
somebody sitting on the sideline being
like yeah keep going guys
um but the the bicode alliance was
formed because they knew that uh this is
something that is cross-industry-wide
it's not something that we can go alone
um and it included a number of major
companies like Microsoft fastly Mozilla
and red hat as as the original founding
members now we're like somewhere around
30 or more and the goal of the bicode
alliance is to build a software
Foundation that allows it for the
webassembly ecosystem that has all the
same properties that we wanted out of
webassembly portability but also Safety
and Security
now from 2020 to 2022 uh you know I feel
obligated to include these These Years
together because I don't know about you
all but the they sort of blur together
for me uh because
um there's a lot of work that happened
around this time but uh there was also a
global pandemic
um but in a lot of ways this really
helped webassembly evolve even more in
trip in more use cases consider for
example Google meet and zoom they both
use webassembly and simd to be able to
blur your background so folks don't have
to see your roommate or whatever Messi
you made for whatever your covid project
that you're working on so around this
time it wasn't just Google meet and and
zoom but you web applications we also
saw folks taking advantage of
webassembly to make it easy to
distribute applications because it's
portable because it's it's very
efficient to download and start we're
starting to see a lot of folks use it
for example in Prime video where if you
have a tiny wrapper of red found your
your application that's running say in a
TV which is kind of a weird environment
to Target if you put a lot of your
business logic within a webassembly
module that piece is the thing that you
can now distribute all around the web
and makes it really easy to update and
so of course most of the streaming
applications today also use webassembly
other awesome things that we're landing
around this time frame was many
different proposals that weren't
included in that initial webassembly
spec
um so a lot of it was around performance
a lot more was added for basically being
able to add more languages that can
Target webassembly including fertile
calls and then now garbage collection
which is getting a lot of excitement and
action right now and we're seeing many
more languages now be able to adopt
webassembly but there were also a lot of
pieces here that laid the groundwork for
what we've heard a little bit before
talking about the component model and
that includes reference types and
multi-value so once those proposals
ended we're able to build the next new
thing which Kelsey started talking about
as the universal computer
so in the present everybody here is
using webassembly every day
it's in many different applications it's
in your Cloud native stack it is uh
honestly the best and probably last
plug-in model you'll ever need if you
want to extend your Envoy application
and there's a talk later talking about
how to extend open policy agent you can
use a webassembly plugin which is really
just a webassembly module to extend it
now another example of what I consider
the plug-in model for a webassembly is
yet another game example so you
shouldn't be surprised you can tell that
I am a gamer and and I do love these
examples this is the Microsoft light
simulator and this is a new thing that
was added this year they made it so that
you can now run webassembly on your Xbox
and the reason to do that is that it
makes it so that instead of having to
download like a dll that lets people
just run random code from other people
on the internet to modify your game you
can now put that in a webassembly
sandbox environment and run that to you
know create new different ways that
controls work and Microsoft flight
simulator now this is actually a really
cool story so I recommend checking that
out now
let's get to the Future this is the cool
part
um
Kelsey talked a little bit about this so
I'm not going to go too deep but most of
us have this problem remember the
original graph that I showed that where
we were building simple spots and
targeting all these different
environments well the reality is uh
they're still doing it exactly that way
um and and many other people are because
we haven't quite made this the reality
but there are places where it can be so
I work at cosmonic we build a paths for
wasm cloud wasm cloud itself is a
distributed application platform for
wasm and so cosmonic being built on wasm
cloud to host wasmcloud modules really
means it's webassembly modules Turtles
all the way down and it's actually a
really wonderful way to develop so this
uh I put it in the future category
because today most people aren't going
to say I'm going to write a new CLI I'm
going to compile it to wasm and then
it'll just show up and work for
everybody right because we're not quite
at the point where there's just a
default this is how I run webassembly
desktop applications today but I think
it's totally in the future probably
within a year or two but we keep talking
a lot about the component model and I
too just like till believe that this is
the future this is has the potential to
be a universal computer that everybody
is able to build on and build on top of
the shoulders now there are a lot of
different features here of the component
model and I'm going to focus more on the
why it's important because as Engineers
we often focus more and wrap ourselves
around the what and the how of things
and there's going to be a lot more talks
talking about in great detail how these
different tools work and to get started
but the why is often just as important
as the what and the how
so with wit this is our now our language
neutral IDL that many different
languages can support and it basically
lets us make it really easy so that we
can interact with high level interfaces
um
for for what we build in a component and
so say you have a wit file an ideal
definition of your API then you can
Target YZ preview 2. use a tool like
whip bind you and to generate your
language bindings so remember when I was
talking a little bit earlier about hey
this this ideal thing is kind of a cool
idea we were talking about it even back
in 2012 and 2014.
um well you know this this this idea is
really a combination of many different
other projects that have come before and
so by being able to take an IDL
definition that lets you talk in high
level languages we can have many other
languages be supported
so what comes out once you run this
build process is a wasm component this
is a new API those first eight bytes is
different between a module and a
component but what comes out is pretty
great remember when I said that a
webassembly module is really a bunch of
numbers in a trench coat
well a webassembly component is really a
bunch of webassembly modules that are in
a trench coat that also know how to talk
to each other
and so by linking them together I'm able
to take languages that are are usually
you never before have I been able to
write a single application that can go
from rust to go to JavaScript but I can
build a portable component and it's
portable because again it's really built
on top of the core webassembly
specification which itself is portable
so once I take a webassembly module
or really a webisably component that has
those high level interfaces I can link
them together and use other webassembly
components as libraries and now this is
what we're talking about when we're
saying we can now build a universal
computer in a lot of ways this is what
we think that Universal computer looks
like
so you might be asking okay why now
um well I believe that a lot of the
reasons why webassembly itself was
successful is a lot of the reasons why
the webassembly component model will
also be successful
it's an open standard you can join a
foundation that's building a lot of the
SDK and tooling around that open
standard through the by code Alliance
and yes many of these different
approaches have been applied before you
you know might throw out Java write once
run anywhere but what's different now is
a combination of a lot of these
different ideas that people have come up
with to be able to do something that's
unique
and so I'm incredibly excited about it
because it also solves real problems
that I've seen including say today when
we have a vulnerability like log for J
We have basically the entire world has
to go and update their application they
have to go update their dependency
recompile their entire app redeploy well
and also retest and then we do this
everywhere so what if we had a common
dependency like a logging component that
a lot of folks pulled in and then all
they had to do was relink they did not
have to recompile their module the
Energy savings alone is massive the cost
is massive costs on people time and work
is massive so there's so many different
things this is just like one use case
that I could pull out that a lot of
people have probably felt this pain
before
but components let us do a lot of other
things like being able to use the right
tool for the job so as Kelsey even
talked about earlier
we've every error of computing we felt
like we had to go and rewrite the entire
world in our in our language so as a go
developer I don't want to enable cigo so
I'm probably not even going to share
code with another back-end engineer that
is writing in Rust for example even
though we're both back in folks we're
both kind of working in the same space
same thing can be said for making it
easy for JavaScript developers to be
able to pull in code from backend
Engineers so that's a type of Silo that
we've built up across the the software
industry really a
a way of fragmenting our ecosystem how
many times has a regular expression
Library been ported from language to
language to language when we got it
right the first time with the parole
expression syntax
now we can also run our components
anywhere so at the time in 2012 it
really felt like the browser in the web
was the final frontier and now what
we're starting to hear is that uh it's
really The Edge it you want to get our
code running as close to our users as
possible and so the edge can be your
phone or your smart watch or your car
there are so many different environments
that we want to Target and also in 2012
at the time I was trying to figure out
how to take basically x86 compilation
and run that everywhere now if you look
at anybody's build Matrix you're looking
at all kinds of different arm and CPU
architectures
and for a lot of the reasons that we've
talked about it's really important to
find ways to make sure our software is
secure and sandboxed
so with the component model we can now
build applications in a new way that
makes it so that they're easily
sandboxed
so
um between that and this concept of
being able to share nothing between our
components components have a linear
memory just like in a webassembly module
but they also don't share memory between
each other so before I showed how we can
have fine-grained capabilities for each
component that we pass through and that
one way of doing that is with Wazi but
we also make it so that we know at a
very granular level exactly what
capabilities any individual component in
a composed application is using and we
know so that this let me step it back
if I pass my keys to the kingdom to Us
application today and that includes like
a bunch of environment variables
including my AWS Keys then what I get
is perhaps a supply chain security
attack where somebody just has access to
getting environment variables and they
go and they know the the typical
environment variable for my AWS key uh
by making it so that I don't even share
memory between the components that are
linked together in that application I
have a new type of application model
that defends against this type of attack
and so this is really a new model for
the current day of software engineering
so I encourage you to get involved the
standardization work is within the w3c
a lot of the tooling and a lot of the
language Mining and that work happens
within the bytecode alliance there are
also several web assembly runtimes that
are hosted within the bicode alliance
including wasm time and the webassembly
micro runtime
in addition to that there's lots of web
assembly runtimes external to the
bytecode alliance and I also encourage
you to jump on the bycode alliance chat
if you're getting started and you're
trying to build things starting with by
code Alliance tooling is probably where
I recommend because I I'm also on the
scene on the technical steering
committee and
why now because it's open and it feels
like 2012 again for me being able to
work with asm.js for the first time
so thank you
[Applause]